over the weekend president buchelli of
el salvador announced that he is going
to create the world's first bitcoin city
what the hell is bitcoin city well
before we talk about bitcoin city we got
to go back and remember el salvador
nobody really even knew where it was on
a map before the beginning of this year
but in june at the bitcoin conference
here in miami they announced with a
partnership of strike and ceo jack
mullers that el salvador was going to
make bitcoin legal tender they not only
went ahead and proposed that legislation
got it passed a couple of days later but
on top of that they have continued to
execute over and over and over again not
only is bitcoin now legal tender in el
salvador but on top of that they also
created a bitcoin wallet and payment
system called chivo over 50 of
salvadorian 6.5 million people in the
country have gone ahead and already
downloaded it and started to use it they
also launched a network of 200 bitcoin
atms throughout their country and some
in the united states as well and then
lastly they also went ahead and created
a bitcoin mining facility that is
plugged into a energy production
facility that is built into the side of
a volcano yes they're using volcanic
energy in order to mine bitcoin all
pretty cool while most people run around
they talk about bitcoin or they propose
these magnificent plans el salvador has
continued to say this is what we're
going to do and then they go and they
execute and for our government not only
do they execute but they execute at a
very very high level and very very
quickly so when president berkeley over
the weekend said that he was going to
build bitcoin city a lot of people
leaned in what exactly does that mean
well the bitcoin city is pretty simple
they're going to build a brand new city
in el salvador at the foot of all of a
volcano and that city is going to have a
couple of key features they're going to
reimagine and use a renewal of old ideas
around energy around space and around
taxation when you start to think about
what that really looks like the first is
that they are going to plug the city
into the volcano what do i mean by that
they are going to use that volcanic
energy in order to make sure that there
is zero zero uh co2 emission and that
that volcanic energy is going to be what
will ultimately power bitcoin city on
top of that too space they are going to
bid build what looks like a circular
type of city that circular type of city
will have a very open middle area a
gathering place for the people of the
city from an aerial view they say that
it will look like the bitcoin logo in
the middle of the city but when
president kelly was talking about the
creation of this new city and the layout
he specifically referenced alexander the
great in all of the cities that he built
back in ancient times alexander the
great built alexandria egypt and has
built one of the most breathtaking
geographic locations and so now
president buchelli going to try to
recreate a lot of that magic in bitcoin
city in el salvador